hey youtubers it's Charlie so Walking
Dead Season 4 is getting ready to come
back on February 9th so welcome to my
first weekly countdown video I'm
probably gonna be doing more than one
video per week for this first one I
wanted to announce the weekly giveaway
that I'm gonna be doing based on each of
the episodes if you've seen my Game of
Thrones kill this video it's gonna be
just like that it's gonna be all about
just predicting who's gonna die on next
week's episode
so whenever episode 9 years we'll be
guessing who's gonna die in episode 10
and so on so forth the prize is gonna be
a $20 Amazon gift card if your
international it'll just be PayPal for
the finale it'll be doubled and I'll
just give away two gift cards and since
they change the international air dates
to be much closer to the US air dates
it'll be a lot easier to do this I know
a lot of you used to have to wait a week
to watch the episodes here are some of
the details each week I'll post my
reviews of the episodes right after the
air in my review video all you have to
do is guess which order the major and
minor characters are going to die in the
next week's episode so inside the
comments of my episode 9 review you'll
be guessing the order people die for
episode 10 the winner each week will be
the first person to guess the correct
order so for example during my episode 9
review you have to be the first person
to guess the correct death order for
episode 10 I will be giving away a gift
card for that first episode so February
2nd the week before it airs I'll be
posting a special video where we'll
guess all the deaths in that episode you
get the idea though we're basically just
guessing who's going to die next week
and in which order for example in my
February 2nd video you might guess that
during episode 9 Bob Stokey is going to
die first and then someone from the
governor's camp just to make it easier
the only characters you have to name
specifically are the main characters
secondary characters like people from
the governor's camp you will totally get
credit for by just saying governor's
camp I will be posting three Walking
Dead videos each week the first one will
always be that episode review that's the
one will you make all your predictions
the second one will be a QA just like
I've been doing for Sherlock and arrow
and the third video will be the kill
list video of that contest video that
will be the results video where I'll
announce the actual order of deaths and
who won the contest based on the
previous week's predictions
it's just intended to be a fun bonus
game just to reward the most hardcore
Walking Dead fans here on my channel so
don't worry if it all sounds super
confusing in my February second video
whenever this starts
I'm gonna explain everything again and
you can always ask questions in the
comments here here are some of the rules
though you have to be a subscriber and
you have to be over 18 or have your
parents permission it's open to anyone
internationally but if you are
international and you win you will get
$20.00 American via PayPal so you do
have to have a PayPal account each week
there will be one winner starting with
episode 9 for the finale there will be
two winners though just as an extra
bonus here's the biggest rule though you
have to be nice or I will disqualify you
so no trolling people in the comments
for the most part I don't think that's
gonna be an issue though everyone here
is really nice and usually trolls aren't
even subscribers so it doesn't really
matter just remember this is all for fun
feel free to ask me any questions you
want in the comments about the contest
or the Walking Dead videos I'm going to
be doing or any related whatnot my next
Walking Dead countdown video is going to
be next Sunday be sure to subscribe to
get it
also if you guys want I will do a Q&A
video this week so just let me know in
the comments if you want that I hope you
guys are looking forward to Walking Dead
coming back as much as I am this is
gonna be a lot of fun that's just why
I'm doing the giveaway because this is
always more fun with friends right now
click here for my top 10 predictions for
the second half of the season careful
for minor spoilers and click here to
find out who I think is gonna die before
the finale thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tonight
high fives